foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
engineer
[Music]
ing
gaming sleeping
that's mathematics mathematics
[Music]
take the biggest scholarship exam for
neet and iidg with up to 100 scholarship
visit infinitylearn.com
give my name
foreign
[Applause]
Advanced courses right you will enroll
yourself for your future planning like
in future planning cards
exactly introduction
s activities
foreign
session
[Music]
third set of all India region wow
fantastic so guys stay tuned cbse
foreign
foreign foreign
[Music]
can you share that one college movement
IIT movement with our future iits
uh actually uh
um
[Laughter]
there's a change in attitude
but once you are there so how did it
change for them actually uh cousin's
sister
so I can't Define in words
idea
I was focusing on
classes
I was like 100 I scored in 10th boats as
well as in science but I wanted to take
biology
I have like in my graduation I also have
a degree in physics and maths questions
foreign
[Laughter]
all right
now
right
classes
guys say hi to all of our students there
right uh this is our teacher's Bay right
though sorry teachers
on the other side you will see those
editors and editing right so sorry
editors
I sit over there
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the live
session by Infinity learn by SRI
chaitanya I am Miss by a maths educator
and over here we are with your J
mathematics faculty so sir exam paper
Solutions
physics
foreign
and Udan 2025 the Udan 2025
that is foreign
so there's so many things
so this is the batch
students
everything you will get in these classes
yes sir
explore
welcome over to you sir
thank you sir okay thank you
foreign
give me some seconds guys and then I'll
start with the solutions over here
okay quick second saw weight Karo so
that we can start with the solutions
over here guys
and then we can move on to uh
set three the palace set one discus this
is the very first question of the set
one over here so let us discuss this
question guys questions
foreign
a is minus one
option second is the correct answer I
hope
yes I hope you understand your all India
region set one has option b is the
correct answer over here TK Alpha plus
beta minus B by so 4 is the correct
answer over here let's move on to the
second question over here guys
so what is the length of the Arc of the
sector of a circle with radius 14
centimeter and central angle 90 any
length of the Arc of formula guys Theta
by 316 to 2 pi right Theta by 316 Theta
is equal to 90 over here so 90 by 360
into 2 pi r so 2 into 22 upon 7 because
nothing is mentioned in the question and
R over here is 14 right so you can just
simplify
okay
so basically 22 centimeter is the answer
is the question clear to every student
over here comments
satisfaction you get right okay you have
done it correctly in the examination or
not I hope it is clear so let us move on
to the next one two triangles are given
to be similar over here and the angles
are given so let us do the question over
here the triangles are a b c and P Q R
they are similar triangles so let us
make the triangles over here A B C
and P Q R over here right
so over here angle a is 32
and we have to find which angle guys we
have to find angle B right and it is
given that angle R is 65 so R is 65 so
you know that corresponding angles of
similar triangles are equal so this will
also be 65 over here so you can find
angle B guys using the angle sum
property so angle B over here will be
180 minus what is the sum of these two
angles
97 so what are you going to get over
here guys you'll get 83 degrees over
here so I hope the question is clear to
you
and you I hope you did it correctly in
the examination I hope it is clear right
so let us take the next question over
here
so if p and Q are natural numbers and P
is a multiple of q p and Q are natural
numbers and P is a multiple of Q then
what is the hcf of p and Q so p is a
multiple of Q so they're going to happen
right
for example 32 into
8. so obviously
your smallest smaller number right p is
a multiple of Q therefore Q is the uh
hcf of these two numbers I hope it is
clear to you so let us move on to the
next question over here
the coordinates of the vertex a of a
rectangle ABC whose three vertices are
given you have to find the vertex a over
here so let us make it guys it's a it's
a rectangle over here
so you have got a rectangle the vertices
uh four vertices are given you have to
find the coordinates of vertex a suppose
it is X comma y over here
and B is 0 comma 0
C is 3 comma 0 over here
and D is 0 comma four so you have to
find the coordinate of the ah vertex a
over here right so you can use this
thing guys if you want
see ah the diagonals of a parallelogram
bisect each are at the point of
intersection so suppose you take this to
be p q the the point of intersection of
the diagonal so if you use midpoint
formula in this diagonal if I talk about
in this diagonal BD so can I say p will
be equal to 0 plus 0 by 2 over here in
the same manner can I say p is equal to
X plus 3 by 2 over here guys X plus
three by two so you can cancel out so
you'll get X is equal to minus three so
you can ah
okay so it means uh let me check it once
again the coordinates are word whose
three vertices are given by b c d 0 0 3
comma zero zero comma four maybe some
value is not correct over here so we
have to find the word coordinates of the
vertex a so X plus 3 by 2
give me something 0 0 3 0 and 0 comma
four right so
X plus 3 by 2 over here so yeah X is
coming out to be minus 3 only so no
option is matching X is coming out to be
minus 3 only over here right
okay let me check it one second the
options are not matching the coordinates
are the vertex a of a rectangle a b c d
whose three vertices are given like this
a b c d so B is 0 comma zero C is three
comma zero and D 0 comma four
so X plus three by two over here and 0
plus 0 by 2 over here so yeah X is
coming out to be minus three over here
right in the same manner if you want to
find y so 0 plus y by 2 will be equal to
1 Guy 0 plus y by 2 will come out to be
0 plus 4 by 2 over here so over here
this will get canceled out and Y is
coming out to be 4. Y is coming out to
be 4 so actually it's a pick guy so
maybe the option is not visible to me
properly I hope it is clear Yeah
question is correct question is not
wrong question is correct the option is
not matching it's a simple question on
the basis of properties of parallelogram
right that there are the diagonals of
parallelogram bisect teacher at the
point of intersection we did many
questions on the basis of this concept
so maybe it is not visible properly over
here I hope it is clear if suppose this
was this would have been -3 then it
would have been correct I hope it is
clear to you Yeah question is correct
correct question is not wrong
so if the pair of equations over here
represent coincident lines then what is
the value over here value of R so
coincident lines what is the property
what is the relationship between the
coefficients of I mean linear equations
in two variables when the lines are
coincidentally conditions are a 1 by A2
is equal to B1 by B2
is equal to C1 by C2 over here right so
just put the values you'll get the
answer so a one by a two over here will
be 3 by 6 and B one by B2 over here will
be minus 1 by
minus r over here so you have to find
the value of R you just need to simplify
this right so R is equal to 2 is the
answer R is equal to 2 is the answer I
hope the question is clear yep it's a
direct question uh for coincident lines
or you can say infinitely many solutions
the condition is a one by a two is equal
to B one by B two is equal to c one by
zero I hope it is clear right
ok so let us move on to the next one
over here a back contains 100 cards
numbered 1 200 a card is drawn at random
from the bag what is the probability
that the number on the card is a perfect
Cube so how many perfect cubes will be
there guys if you start from one to
hundred
so uh the maximum will be see 4 cube is
64 4 cube is 64 and 5 cube is uh 125 5
cube is 125 so only four I mean between
1 200 I'm starting from one and
including 100 as well only four perfect
Cube numbers will be there so the
probability will be 4 upon 100 so the
answer is
ah 1 by 25 so this is the answer I hope
the question is clear hello Vijay
welcome to the session so let's move on
to the next one guys let us complete it
quickly uh the pair of equations over
here graphically represent which line so
whenever you make graph over here
actually this question was asked or
maybe it was there in the sample paper
two years back as well maybe the second
last year so X is equal to a and Y is
equal to B so X is equal to a will be
somewhat like this and Y is equal to B
will be somewhat like this guys this is
your x axis the y axis and the origin so
the point of intersection will be a
comma B over here right so they will
intersect at Point a comma B is it clear
to everyone hello mithali welcome to
this session
any doubt in this one guys 20 stone over
here it's a simple question the lines
will be perpendicular to each other
ok so let us take the next one if one
zero of this polynomial is 0 is
reciprocal of the other then you have to
find the value of K so 1 0 is reciprocal
of the other so product of zeros will be
what it is C by a over here so over here
you can say that c is equal to a so what
is c c is the constant term and I am
sorry guys actually the pick is not
clear I am just assuming that it is
minus maybe in your set it would have
been positive but I hope you understand
that so C is equal to a is the
coefficient of x square so that is equal
to 6 over here so you can say k minus 2
is equal to minus 6 so therefore K is
equal to minus 4 I am assuming that it
is minus 4 uh I'm assuming this is minus
sign so therefore option A is correct
maybe in your set it it is plus over
here but over here I am seeing this only
because we have got paper like sometimes
back only I hope it is clear to every
student over here simple question right
let us do the next one over here what is
the total surface here of a solid
hemisphere of diameter this so total
surface area of a solid hemisphere of
radius R is what guys radius R is 3 Pi R
square you remember this so in terms of
diameter you have to find so diameter is
uh radius you have to write
d by 2 over here so this will give you
what 3 Pi d square by 4. So This Is The
Answer 3 Pi d square by four so option D
is the correct answer I hope it is clear
to you
okay so let us move on to the next one
over here guys
if three coins are tossed simultaneously
what is the probability of getting at
most one tail
C so when you have got three coins at
most one Tails means maximum one tail so
it means you have to take zero tail and
you have to take one tail as well now
you have to write the outcomes when you
get three coins when you toss three
coins simultaneously so the outcomes are
like this guys
I'm writing the outcomes
so you want a zero tail and one tail
over here right so zero tail so this
will come up and one tail one tail one
tail
and over here okay
okay so the answer will be four by eight
right so options are given like this
option b is correct I hope it is clear
option b is coming out to be correct
vinay I hope it is clear to you
thank you yadnish I hope it is clear
guys
at most one tail it cannot be uh that uh
option D it cannot be at most one tail
means zero tail and one tail will be
taken I hope it is clear so let us take
the next one so over here you see D is
parallel to B uh BC over here so you can
directly use basic proportionality
theorem it's a direct question right
ah what you have to find yeah we have to
find X then you have to use basic
proportionality theorem only this upon
this is equal to this upon this so
straightforward question two by three is
equal to 3 by X over here so X will be
what guys X will be 9 by 2 so this is
the answer right so direct question on
the basic proportionality theorem I hope
it is clear to every stone in the class
just comment in the chart I'm not
getting any comments or if it is clear
or not and you've got it correctly or
not at least you can compare with your
see I have seen all the three uh sets I
mean I'm talking about all India sets so
almost every question will was were the
same I had seen only two or three
questions were different all of them
were same but obviously I cannot explain
all the questions simultaneously so
therefore we are going in a sequence
right so therefore I am taking the first
set first
so the r hand of a clock is this the
angle should bite between 720 and 755 C
so when you start from 7 and you are
going up till eight what is the angle
covered guys angle covered will be 360
degrees or not tell me
so in one minute what is the angle
covered in one minute this will be the
angled angle covered or not tell me six
degrees over here yes or no
now you have to cover the angle ah
wait give me some seconds
okay it is our hand right ah
okay fine I'm sorry it was not it is not
minute hand our hand the angle will be
what guys
so if you have got somewhat like this in
uh suppose in one hour what is the angle
covered by the hour hand so it will be
basically uh
360 divided by
12 right
give me some seconds
okay give me some seconds guys I will
take this question later on first I'll
take the next question so that we can do
it quickly right I hope it is clear to
you so the zeros of the polynomial are
given by so you have to factorize it's a
direct question on the basis of zeros
guys over here
direct question on the basis of zero so
over here this will be X plus 3 X plus
one over here so the zeros of the
polynomial are minus three comma minus
one I hope it is clear right
yes I hope the question is clear to
everybody over here so let us take the
next question guys
so over here we have to find what is p a
plus c s suppose this is X over here
guys C
if this is X this will also be X if this
is y this will also be y over here so
what is p a plus c s so p a plus c s is
also X Plus y over here you see because
the lens of tangents drawn from an
external point to a circle are equal so
p a plus c s is X Plus y so P X Plus Y
is also equal to t s over here so this
option is correct I hope the question is
clear to you
any doubt in this one
ok so let us take the next one over here
guys
so Alpha and beta the zeros of the
quadratic polynomial then you have to
find the value of alpha square plus beta
Square so we have done many times
questions like this guys so Alpha square
plus beta Square can be written as Alpha
plus beta the whole Square minus 2 Alpha
Beta right
and Alpha plus beta is minus B by a
right uh if you talk about the standard
form of a quadratic polynomial it is ax
square plus b x plus C so over here what
is Alpha plus beta guys Alpha plus beta
is minus of minus a by one so that is a
over here and what is Alpha plus beta it
is C by a so it is minus B by 1 so it is
minus B over here right so just put the
values over here Alpha plus beta is a
square minus 2 into Alpha Beta is minus
B over here
so a
so a square plus 2 B is the answer I
hope the question is clear to everybody
okay so let's do this let's see the next
one
so option C is the correct answer in
this one
if you talk about question 15 option C
is the correct answer okay
maths Guru
okay
now you have to find the area of the
triangle formed by the line with the
coordinate axis area of the triangle
form by the coordinate axis so over here
if you will make its graph guys
you can plot the points basically it is
not there in grade 10 so you have to
plot the points only so if you put X is
equal to 0 y will be equal to B if you
put Y is equal to 0 over here
X is equal to a so a comma 0 and 0 comma
B it will be so a comma 0 and 0 comma B
so you have to find the area of the
triangle over here so you see this
distance is a units and this distance is
B unit so what is its area half into
base into height so half into base a b
is the answer I hope the question is
clear to you right
yep
so let us take the next one over here
guys
so over here again this is a similarity
question only let us do it
a b is parallel to P Q over here if a b
is equal to
six see these triangles will be similar
guys because you see these sides are
parallel so this angle will be equal to
this angle alternate interior angles
this angle is equal to this angle
alternate interior angles so basically
you can write the names properly
otherwise it will be wrong so a b o is
similar to a b o is similar to uh p o q
right ah not sorry a b o is similar to
qpo right
QP over here so you can write the ratio
of the corresponding sides over here we
have to find op right so write it
properly o p by if I take it like this
op by OB
will be equal to I can take p q by a b
over here right p q by a b ratio of
corresponding sides of two similar
triangles are equal so op I do not know
over here OB
is uh 3
and P Q is equal to 2 and a b is equal
to 6 over here right so three twos are
six o p is coming out to be one
centimeter right op is coming out to be
one centimeter any doubt in the equation
guys yes
so let us take the next question over
here okay assertion reason questions
over here so a tangent to a circle is
perpendicular to the radius through the
point of contact this statement is true
tangent to a circle is perpendicular to
the radius to the point of contact the
length of tangent is drawn from an
external point to a circle are equal
both of them are correct but
uh okay so over here
reason is not the correct explanation of
the answer so over here what will be the
answer over option b will be the answer
they are true but the reason is not the
correct explanation of the answer I hope
it is clear
in the same manner this polynomial over
here they are having two real zeros a
quadratic polynomial can have at most
two real zero see the reason is correct
over here quadratic polynomials two real
zeros so for this you have to find the
discriminant discriminant is equal to b
square minus four AC over here so b
square is what three Square minus 4
a c so this is basically ah
which is basically negative so it is not
having real zeros right it is not having
real zeros because discriminant is
negative so nine miles for this yeah so
this is not having real zero so it is
wrong so I share assertion is wrong and
reason is correct so you can check
according to that okay assertion is
wrong and reason is correct over here
let us move on to the next one so you
have to prove that this is an irrational
number it is already given that root 3
is an irrational number so you don't
have to actually prove root 3 and
irrational number over here right so
what you have to do again this question
we had done in the previous class as
well in the marathon session and in many
times I had explained this one so you
can just assume that 2 plus root 3 is a
rational number where p and Q are
integers and Q is not equal to 0. so
over here it is not compulsory to assume
p and Q to be Co prime numbers you just
have to assume p and Q to be integers
and Q is not equal to zero so what you
have to you just have to separate root 3
over here separate out root 3 this is p
by Q minus 2 and then you can write it P
minus 2 Q by Q over here so over here p
and Q are integers right p and Q are
integers we have already assumed them to
be integers and Q is a non-zero integer
so ratio of two integers will be what
guys but denominator is not zero so this
is a rational number so on the right
hand side it is a rational number on the
left hand side
I'm sorry yeah this is an irrational
number right
so this is the contradiction and
irrational number cannot be equal to a
rational number and this contradiction
arises to a wrong Assumption of assuming
2 plus root 3 to be a rational number
this you have to write in your answer if
you will not write it properly you will
not get full marks even if you have done
it correctly so I hope it is clear let
us move on to the next one
so over here we have to find the value
of P so let us put the values and we'll
get the answer its just simplification
thing right so chord 45 is what guys
chord 45 is one only what is SEC UH 60
660 is reciprocal of cos 60 cos 60 is
what
cos 60 sine 30 sine 30 is half so this
is 2 over here right now sine 60 is root
3 by 2
so this is root 3 by 2 the whole square
plus p and that is equal to three by
four now if you simplify this will come
out to be three by four only three by
four three by four will get canceled out
you see this is four this is also 4. so
basically p is coming out to be 0. p is
coming out to be 0 over here now this
question I had taken in the on in the
board Master Series and in many a times
on this YouTube channel as well this is
a very famous question you have to find
the value of sine square a plus sine
raised power 4A if this is equal to one
so from here what we can say guys cos a
is equal to 1 minus cos square a right
so this is nothing but sine square a
this is sine square a over here right so
over here we have to simplify this
see don't change it because if you will
change both of them simultaneously not
get the answer so this is basically sine
square a
in place of this thing can I write like
this sine square a the whole square
right now what is sine square a in place
of sine square a I can write cos a yes
or no so basically this will come out to
be sine square a in place of sine square
a I will write cos square a so it is cos
square a only
in place of sine square a I will write
cos a basically so it will be cos square
a so sine square a plus cos square is
one so one is the answer I hope it is
clear
so let us take the next thing over here
guys
show that these points are the vertices
of a right angle triangle so basically
you have to find the distance over here
guys
so these are the vertices of a right
angle triangle so suppose this is a b c
I don't know the value so therefore I
can assume anything so a b so basically
if you want to prove a right angle
triangle you have to prove the you have
to show that the Pythagoras Theorem is
getting satisfied so we can find a b
square over here
so a b square will be what so when you
use the distance formula guys and if you
have used the square over here itself
maybe I will show you in the first case
so this will be what guys this will be 8
minus of minus 2 so it will be 8 plus 2
I am doing it directly I hope you
understand that so 8 plus 2 it will give
you 10 square right and over here this
is 3 minus three so basically 0 only
so this will give this square root will
get removed guys so basically you will
get 10 square only and that is 100 over
here so in the same manner if I directly
find b c Square over here if I find b c
Square I don't need to write this square
root once again because anyways I am
squaring over here right so BC will be
what if I do
6 minus 8 the whole square root I am not
putting over here I hope you understand
so 6 minus 8 the whole square that is
minus 2 the whole Square
plus 7 minus 3 that is 4 Square
and this will give you what guys this is
16 plus 4
20. in the same manner a c Square I can
find so AC Square will be what AC Square
over here will be ah
see this will be 6 minus of minus 2 that
is
8 square right so this is 8 square plus
and this will be 7 minus 3 the whole
Square which is equal to 4 Square so
what is this equal to guys this is 64
plus 16 is 80 right so what you can see
over here you can see that a b square a
b square is coming out to be BC square
plus a c square or not you can see the
things over here this is hundred so b c
square plus AC square is equal to a b
square so you can say that Pythagoras
Theorem is getting is getting satisfied
in this thing so basically the right
angle triangle will be like this a b
square
is equal to BC square plus AC Square so
therefore angle C is equal to 90 degree
so therefore this vertex is containing
the right angle I hope it is clear you
have to show that in your answer sheet
obviously by the converse of the
Pythagoras Theorem I hope it is clear
uh okay but obviously right now I can do
this one first
because I cannot discuss multiple papers
simultaneously I hope you understand
that so the length of the shadow of a
tar and on the plane ground is root 3
times the height of the tar
so let us do the figure
length of the shadow of a tar on the
plane ground is root 3 times
so you see you see this is the Tower and
its shadow is root three times the
height of the tar so you have to find
the angle of elevation of the Sun so
this is the angle of elevation of the
sun guys this is the angle of elevation
of the Sun so you can directly take over
here tan Theta see obviously I am not
writing every statement over here I hope
you understand that okay but obviously
you must have written this statement if
you will not write these statements you
will not get full marks even if your
answer is correct but I am explaining it
therefore I am not writing everything so
tan Theta is coming out to be 1 by root
3 therefore you can say Theta is equal
to 30 degrees
I hope it is clear now the second part
the angle of Illusion is the top star
from point on the ground which is 30
meter away from the foot of the tar is
30. it means the figure is somewhat like
this
point on the ground which is 30 meter
and the angle of elevation of the top or
top of the tar is 30 degree you have to
find the height of the tar suppose it is
H so the same thing you have to use tan
30 over here will be equal to what guys
perpendicular upon base so it is height
upon 30 tan 30 is what guys it is one by
root 3 over here
so this is H upon 30 so you can cross
multiply H will come out to be 30 by
root 3. you can further simplify it you
can further simplify by multiplying by
root 3 in the numerator as well as the
denominator you see over here root 3
into root 3 is 3 so this is ten so 10
root 3 meter is the answer I hope the
question is clear to everybody
ok so let us take the next one over here
so again you cannot expect a question
more simple than this in circles
so everything is given over here if DAC
is given you have to find the measure of
boc so you know that this angle is 90
this angle is 90 because stringent to a
circle is perpendicular to the radius to
the point of contact so if you see a
quadrilateral a b o c in this
quadrilateral you can use the angle sum
property so ah see this is 90 this is
90. so in this quadrilateral this plus
this is 180 right B plus C is 180 so
therefore angle a plus angle o is also
180. we use the angle sum property in
this quadrilateral
that's it so angle a is given to be 65
plus angle o is equal to 180 degrees so
this is nothing but angle over here is
equal to 115 degrees this is the answer
and obviously you have to write
statements wherever applicable you
cannot directly say that these angles
are supplementary because that is not
given as a theorem in ncert right you
have to prove that it is I mean these
two angles are supplementary you have to
write it in your answer sheet I hope the
question is clear so angle boc is
nothing but angle o so it is coming out
to be 115 degrees over here let us take
the next question guys
so by prime factorization the LCM of the
numbers this and this is this also find
the hcf of the two numbers
so I hope you can do this guys you just
have to find the LCM I'm explaining this
because it's a big number so I have to
do its prime factorization and I guess
you have done that
weight
okay so uh actually I had done it so
LCM is coming or I don't exactly
remember I don't need to I think do it
because see LCM you can find by doing
the prime factorization of these numbers
and hcf into LCM you know that is equal
to the product of the numbers SCF into
LCM will come out to be the product of
the numbers that is one eight one eight
zero and seven five seven five right
I hope it is okay with you
so just do this obviously if you will
find the LCM you can find the hcfs and
obviously if you have done the prime
factorization you can get the LCM LCM
over from there only right cyclic
quadrilateral property there is no
property like that in ncrt Kabir I hope
you understand that
there is no property like that in ncert
cyclic quadrilateral property in grade
10 right so you can find the hcf and LCM
if you will do the prime factorization
of this number now the second part three
bells ring at intervals this and this if
all the three belts rang at 6 M then
when will they ring together again so
then you will have to find the LCM of
these values over here right LCM of 6 12
and 18 over here so LCM of these values
will be what guys
that will be equal to 36 minutes right
that will be equal to 36 minutes if you
find the LCM of them so if they started
ringing at 6 am simultaneously the next
time they will ring will be 6 36 am I
hope it is clear to you the question
this was simple calculation therefore I
did it this one you can do it's a big
number right you can do the prime
factorization of it I hope it is clear
to you
okay
let us take the next one over here so
over here you just need to change in
sign and cos you'll get the answer let
us do this
just change in sign cost you'll get the
answer the left hand side over here if
you will simplify it what will you get
guys just simplify you'll get 1 minus
cos Square Theta upon cos Theta
into 1 minus sine Square Theta upon sine
Theta
and that is equal to what 1 minus cos
square is sine Square Theta upon cos
Theta guys this is sine Square Theta
upon cos Theta and one minus sine Square
Theta is cos Square Theta so this is cos
Square Theta upon sin Theta right
so basically basically if you simplify
you'll get sine Theta cos Theta over
here sine Theta cos Theta over here in
the answer I hope it is clear so you can
just simplify you will get the answer
where the right hand side of this thing
over here is just change in sine and cos
tan Theta is nothing but sin Theta by
cos Theta
plus cot Theta is cos Theta by sine
Theta right
so if you take the LCM in the
denominator what will you get guys
cos Theta sin Theta will go in the
numerator so sine Theta cos Theta
divided by
sine Square theta plus cos Square Theta
is nothing but 1. so you see this is
coming out to be equal to sin Theta cos
Theta only and that is the proof of this
I hope it is clear you cannot expect
that this simple trigonometric identity
will come in the examination yesterday
also I was taking ah not yesterday the
day before you say I was taking the mega
marathon session where students were
really worried about trigonometric
identity but you see this is a very
simple trigonometric identity right
which you have to prove in the
examination so if 0 comma 1 is
equidistant from this point in this we
have to find the values of X over here
so you just can use the distance form
let us given that
p q equidistant from P and R
so this is R cube right so over here we
can square on both these sides so p q
square is equal to r q Square over here
you can use the distance formula so p q
Square over here will be
P minus 0 the whole square plus
minus 3 minus 1 the whole Square
and that is equal to r q Square over
here so r q Square will be x square
plus 5 Square so you see we can cancel
out five square over here so this is
basically x square is equal to ah
basically you can say 16. so from here x
will come out to be plus minus 4 I hope
it is clear to every sweat over here x
is 0 plus minus 4 is the answer
I hope this is clear
okay so let us move on to the next one a
car has two wipers
ah we are doing all India set one Anika
I hope it is clear to you so a car has
two wipers which do not overlap each
wiper has a blade of length this
sweeping through an angle of 120 find
the total area cleaned at each sweep of
the two blades so you see it is somewhat
like this you've got a car I mean this
situation is like this yes or no so
wiper is like this ah oh sorry it's not
exact basically weight
each is having 120 degrees right
so it will be somewhat like this it will
look somewhat like this
and this suppose this wiper can sweep
like this and the other wiper can sweep
like this they are not overlapping each
other right this is the situation and
the length of each wiper is 21
centimeter 21 centimeter over here and
the central angle is 120 degrees
for both of them the central angle is
120 degrees so it is a simple question
you have to find the area over here
right
so this thing you have to find so area
of two equal sectors you have to
multiply two into area one sector is
Theta by Three Sixty into Pi R square so
that is 120 upon 360 into Pi is 22 upon
7 because radius is given to be a
multiple of seven only so Pi R square so
just simplify you will get the answer
guys that's it
So This Is The Answer 44 into 21 you can
multiply you'll get the answer 44 into
centimeters square is it centimeter
obviously it will be in centimeter
because it is a car I hope it is clear
to you right just multiply I'll get the
answer let us take the next one
so if the system of linear equations
have infinite number of solutions then
you have to find the values of A and B
obviously you will get a pair of linear
equations in two variables you must have
done questions like this right so
infinite number of solutions so over
here uh
what is the condition for infinite
number of solutions a one by a two is
equal to B one by B two is equal to c
one by C two right B one by B two is
equal to c one by C2 over here right so
over here I can say
2 by 2 a
is equal to 3 by a plus b
and that's it that is 7 by 28 so 7 4S
are 28 right so you can ah compare these
two you'll get the value of a guys two
by two you can simplify all the weight
okay
so if you multiply cross multiply you'll
get a is equal to 4 over here so a is
equal to 4 is the answer now if you want
you can take these two what will you get
over here guys 1 by a is equal to 3 by a
plus b so a is equal to 4 we have got
first cross multiplies you will get ah 4
plus 4 is what eight
wait wait wait wait
this is B guys yes or no
this is B over here right
so a b have got to be equal to 4 and
this is a plus b over here just cross
multiply so a plus b is equal to three a
over here so B is coming out to be equal
to 2A and the value of
a we have got to be equal to four so
four twos are eight is the answer I hope
it is clear okay
fine now over here you have got this
question you have done many times in the
mega marathon session in in many other
sessions I discussed this method when
the coefficients are interchanging you
just have to add and subtract that's it
just add and subtract you'll get the
you'll get the values of X Plus y so if
you will add what are you getting uh
348 into X Plus Y and that will be equal
to
17 40 you are getting so what is the
value of x plus y over here guys X Plus
y will come out to be equal to
5 only right it will be 5.
so if you subtract once what will you
get over here if you subtract you'll get
ah
so 86 into x minus y and that will come
out to be equal to I think
86 only so X Plus Y is nothing but equal
to 1. so what you can do now you can
just add and subtract these equations
and you'll get the values of X and Y so
add just add them once you'll get 2x is
equal to 6 over here 2x is equal to 6 so
X is equal to 3 and uh if you put the
value of x suppose over here so you'll
get 3 minus y is equal to 1 so Y is
equal to 2 I hope the answer is question
is clear to you so simple question only
right you must have done this question
many a times
and this was obviously one of the
important questions you can do so over
here the situation is somewhat like this
see construction is also given although
if it would not have been given in the
question it would have made it easier ah
tougher
so you have to prove that q a p plus
angle a p r is equal to 90. see over
here
simple proof it is
radii of the same Circle are equal right
so o a is equal to op they are equal to
the radius of the circle radius right
now angle supposed to equal sides of a
triangle are equal so oaps suppose X so
this will also be X or naught because
angles opposite to equal sides of a
triangle are equal so over here
and also you can see that o p r is equal
to 90 or not because tangent to a circle
is perpendicular to the radius to the
point of contact this is 90 yes or no so
if you take the left hand side what is
angle q a p if you take q a p plus angle
a p r
right so q a p is nothing but X and in
place of a p r
in place of APR can I write 90 minus X
over here so I can write 90 minus X so
have I proved it it's a direct proof
right but obviously see I am proving
these things I am not writing statements
but obviously ah obviously first we'll
do this
if this question is in the examination
of you write every statement possible
you cannot do it like this right I'm
just explaining it how it is to be done
I hope it is clear so let us take the
next one over here
so how many terms of this arithmetic
progression must be taken so that the
sum is 180 explain the double answer so
let us do this question
how many sums it means uh
SN is given to be 180 over here right so
SN is what guys n by 2 into 1 8 n by 2
into 2A so 2A will be what guys 2 into
45 so that is 90 plus n minus 1 and what
is d for this AP D is equal to 39 minus
13 wait 39 minus 45 right so that is
equal to minus 6 yes
so this is coming out to be 180 it is
not degrees I am sorry this is not
degree okay so n by 2 into 2 A Plus n
minus 1 D is minus 6 that is equal 180.
so let's simplify this will get the
answer so you will get n into 90
minus 6 n
plus 6
and that is equal to just cross multiply
this is 360 over here
so what will you get over here guys n
minus 6 n
plus 96 that is equal to 360. can I
divide on both these sides by 6 over
here guys it will make it simpler so
this will give you n into minus n Plus
16 and that is equal to 60. I hope this
is clear now let's simplify it further
so this will give you minus n square
plus 16 and minus 60 that is equal to 0
so you can divide by minus and minus 1
on both the sides you'll get n Square
minus 16 and plus 60 that is equal to 0
so if you simplify if you factorize it's
a direct middle term splitting thing so
you see 10 6 are 60. so I can do it like
this n minus 10 and minus 6 that is
equal to 0 over here so the value of n
is coming out to be 10 and 6 10 and 6 it
is coming right now you have to explain
the double answer that how it is
possible that some of the first 10 terms
that is s 10 is equal to S6 is equal to
ah 180 so how is it even possible the
question is this you have to explain
that so basically this situation is like
this s 10 is equal to S6 it means that
if you start from first term second term
and dot dot dot dot suppose up till s is
6 right A6 A7 and you're moving up till
8 10. so what does it mean that sum of
the first 10 terms and the sum of the
first six terms they are equal so what
does it mean that this Gap this this sum
of these terms is equal to zero if the
sum of the first 10 terms in the sum of
the first six terms they are equal it
means the sum of these terms is equal to
0 it means 7 8 9
and 10 these the sum of these terms is
equal to zero I hope it is clear to you
you can think it naturally
I hope this is clear any doubt in this
thing guys
okay so let us move on to the next thing
over here
so as observed from the top of 75 meter
high Lighthouse from the sea level the
angle of depression of the two ships are
30 degrees and 60 degrees if one ship is
exactly behind the other on the same
side of the lighthouse find the distance
between the two ships
so we have done many questions like this
these are ncert type questions only as
observed from the top of a 75 meter I'm
doing over here guys I hope you
understand due to lack of space
so suppose this is the lighthouse and
from this Lighthouse angle of depression
is given to you
30 and 60 right so if this is 30
overhead so alternate interior angles
are equal this will also be 30 and if
this total is 60 this will also be 60
right alternate interior angles are
equal and obviously this is 90.
so ah 75 meter high Lighthouse 75 meter
high Lighthouse what we have to find
over here you have to find the distance
between the two ships so it means we
have to find this suppose this is X we
have to find this the distance between
the two ships right and suppose this is
why because we'll use this because
without this we won't be able to do this
do this question so I hope this
situation is clear to you will get two
equations and you can solve these two
equations suppose if I take tan 30 over
here what is tan 30 tan 30 if you see
from the figure it will be 75 upon X
Plus y 75 upon X Plus y now tan Thirty
is one by root 3 so from here we'll get
X Plus y to be equal to 75 root 3 if you
cross multiply so this is the first
equation over here now if you take this
triangle over here and you want tan 60
over here so tan 60 is equal to what
guys it is 75 upon y over here right 75
upon y so you can cross multiply so from
here y will be equal to what tan 60 is
root 3 so it is 75 by root 3 so you can
further simplify by multiplying and
dividing by root 3 over here so root 3
into root 3 is 3 so 3 and 3 2 6 3 5 that
ah
15 okay so this is coming out to be 25
root 3 meter I hope it is clear so you
see Y is coming out to be 25 root 3
meter X Plus by 75 root 3 meter we want
the value of x so just see this
situation X is nothing but 75 root 3
minus y over here so Y is also equal to
25 root 3 so this will give you 75 root
3 minus 25 root 3 right so the answer is
coming out to be basically 50 root 3. 50
root 3 is the answer and obviously you
have to put put over here root 3 0 to
1.732 so just put it 1.732 meter three
only so this is divided by 100 and this
is two times you will get
86.5 meter is the answer I hope it is
clear
I hope the question is clear
now the second part of I hope the
question is just confirm in the chat
Mr amazing is it clear hello pardeep
welcome to the session no we are doing
the first session first uh
set only Mr amazing hello pradeep hi Pro
is it clear hello
okay fine obviously you just have to
compare that's it so I'm deleting it
guys because we have to do this next
question over here itself so from point
on the ground the angular solution the
bottom and the top see these are very
simple questions now I'm being very
honest from a point on the ground the
angle of elevation of the bottom and top
of a transmission are fixed at the top
of 30 meter high building it means
somewhat like this
transmission tar on the top of a 30
meter high building
so this is the situation right this is
the
fixed at the top 30 meter high building
this is the 30 meter high building right
same situation this is also 90 over here
so 30 and 60 angle of elevation is 30
and 60. this is 30 over here and this is
60 obviously over here right this thing
is given
Now find the height of the transmission
tower you have to find the height of the
transmission tower
so suppose this is X over here and
suppose this thing is why it's a it's a
simple question right so you can do 1060
10 30 you will get the answer suppose I
am doing tan 30 over here right
tan 30 will be what guys over here it
will be 30 by y or not tell me now tan
Thirty is one by root 3 so y will come
out to be 30 root 3 over here right Y is
30 root 3 this part is done over here
clear now we can do tan 60 now tan 60 is
what over here tan 60 will be
uh X plus 30 by Y X plus 30 by y now tan
60 is root 3 guys this is root 3 Y is
coming out to be Y is coming out to be
30 root 3 30 root 3 over here and that
is equal to X plus 30 over here now this
is what root 3 into root 3 is 3 so 13 to
3 is 19 90 minus 3 30 60 so X is equal
to 60 meter is the answer I hope it is
clear to everybody in the class
paper level was I would say easy only
one or two questions I mean only one
mark question one or two questions are
tricky otherwise
ah this set is set one only all India
set one okay standard set one yeah all
India standard set one Resort two
pardeep
this is not two right now
ok so I hope this is clear let us take
the next one you have to find the mean
and median so I hope you would have done
it I mean do I need to actually do it
guys I I think you can do it right you
just have to find mean and median so you
can use any method is all up to you
use any method by which you can find the
mean over here right
so due to space Also I have got some
problem I hope you understand that thing
so 0 to 10 10 20 this seventy eighty ten
twenty
twenty Thirty
Thirty forty
forty fifty
eighty it is up till 80 right yeah so it
is 7 14 13 12 7 14 13 12
and 2011 15 8. 20 11 15 8. now we can
find the class Mark over here guys I am
sorry that due to space issues I'm doing
over here only class Mark is 5 over here
guys and this is 30. so class Mark is 15
so it will be 25 35
45 55
65 75 these are the class marks now out
of these you can take the middle most
value to be the assumed mean so see
three values over here and three values
over here so suppose I am taking this
one as the assumed mean only right so
from here what you can do you can find
the deviations d i is equal to x i minus
a over here I hope it is clear to you so
x i minus a this is 35 minus this will
give you minus 30 minus 20
minus 10 0
20 30
40. I hope it is clear up till here now
we have to find f i d i over here right
we have to find fidi
so these are f i over here guys
obviously you can do it but still I'm
doing 7 minus 210 degrees over here
and this is
minus 280 and this will be minus 130
over here and this is 0 over here and
this is
200 over here
and this will give you
220 over here and this will give you
450 over here and this will give you 320
over here right so I hope it is clear
now you can find Sigma fidi over here
guys what is Sigma fidi can you tell me
guys so this will be basically 0
and then you have got
and then you have to subtract 0
so this will give you
570 right this is coming out to be 570
over here is it clear
yeah it is not visible because there is
some issue over here I mean to write I
hope you understand that
yep
so I hope it is clear to you so this is
570 now sum of all the frequencies will
be what guys some of all the frequencies
if you will calculate over here this
will give you
is it is coming out to be 120 so just
calculate it I hope you guys understand
that it's just calculations
okay
so this is coming out to be 100 is
already given over there so mean will be
what guys X bar is equal to a plus Sigma
f i d i upon Sigma f i right A Plus
Sigma f i d i upon Sigma Phi this
formula you already know so a over here
we have assumed to be 35
Sigma fidi is coming out to be again
please check the calculation but I must
I hope it is correct and sigma f i is
100 over here so just calculate you will
get the answer so this will be ah
40.7 right 40.7 is the equation clear
40.7 it is coming out yeah Sigma fi is
already given that is correct
yeah is it clear to everybody
now again I hope you understand median
also you can find over here itself right
median ah I am not calculating again
because it will take time only but still
I can find cumulative frequencies for
you right so this is 7
and this will be what guys
and this will be 100 right obviously
Sigma this is nothing but n now what is
n by 2 N by 2 is 50. so Q ah the
cumulative of the cumulative frequency
of the class just greater than n by 2 is
what just greater than n by 2 is this so
this is the median class or not guys
tell me this is the median class so
median will be what guys L plus h into
the formula is L plus h into n by 2
minus c f upon F and by 2 minus c f upon
f
so L is what over here lower limit of
the median class H is the class size
over here n by 2 is what 50
minus c f is the cumulative frequency of
the class preceding the median class
cumulative frequency of the class
preceding the median class f is the
frequency of the median class so that is
20. so is it clear to every student over
here so if you will simplify this is
nothing but 2 over here and this is 4 so
it is 2 so 42 is the median which is
coming out over here is it clear to
everybody over here
it is not like that amazing I would say
the paper was very simple if you talk
about the level of the questions and
complexity as well
I would say that I hope it is clear to
everybody right
okay fine so let us move on to the next
one
ncrt question this is sites a b and BC
and median a d of a triangle ABC are
respectively proportional see obviously
I am not writing everything possible
science a b b c and median a d
a b b c and median a d so a b b c
and median a d of a triangle
are respectively proportional to sites p
q QR and PM p q r
and PM over here right
so this is a median so this is equal to
this and this is equal to this over here
right
so you have to show that a b c is
similar to pqr it's a very simple
question over here because ah wait it is
given to us
that a b by P Q is equal to BC by q r b
c by q r
and is equal to a d by PM right it is
given a d by PM over here
now guys in place of BC by q r it is
given that a d is a median and PM is a
median so in place of BC can I write 2bd
over here can I write 2bd and in place
of a q r can I write a 2q m tell me so
this will get canceled out so basically
a b by P Q is equal to a d by PM is
equal to b d by q m have we proved guys
so can we not say over here therefore
triangle ABD is similar to Triangle a b
d
is similar to p q m over here by SSS
similarity Criterion yes or no they are
similar by SSS similarity Criterion over
here and if they are similar by SSS
similarity Criterion we can say that
angle B is equal to angle Q because
corresponding angles of similar
triangles are equal now what you are
seeing over here if you see a b c and P
Q R it is already given that this upon
this is equal to this upon this and we
have proved angle B is equal to angle Q
so can we not say that therefore a b c
is similar to a b c is similar to p q r
by SAS similarity Criterion by SAS
similarity Criterion they are similar I
hope it is clear
I will do the whole set okay because oh
no see in set to almost every question
is same only I have seen this set two as
well pradeep it is not like that
okay we'll see that we'll see that as
well amazing no problem I hope it is
clear to every student over here in the
class
ok
now let us do the next part through the
midpoint M of the side C D of a
parallelogram ABCD
let us make the figure uh
wait
through the midpoint m
of the side C D of a parallelogram a b c
d
so this is a b c d and through the
midpoint
M of the size CD are taking midpoint M
of side C D or the parallelogram ABCD
the line b m is drawn intersecting
AC in l and a d at
wait wait through the midpoint M of the
side C D of a parallelogram a b c d okay
fine line b m is drawn intersecting AC
okay intersecting AC
in l
and
wait I'll have to make the figure once
again properly because
I am also obviously seeing it for the
first time right now wait
give me some seconds guys
maybe I'll may go through the midpoint M
of the sides CD of a parallelogram a b c
d
midpoint of the side CD
the line BM is drawn intersecting AC in
l
ok fine
this is the figure guys AC in l
OK a C and L and A D produced in E I
hope it is clear now we have to prove
that e l is equal to 2bl right we have
to prove that e l is equal to 2bl so how
can we do this one guys tell me
so uh
we have to prove over here e l is equal
to 2 BL so I think
so can I take this triangle over here
guys give me some seconds because the
space is also maybe I'll take the next
question first so that we can take the
next question in the last so that I can
take it quickly okay
so we have to we have this situation
over here what is the area of the
quadrant odco OD
o so this is very simple area of the
quadrant odco will be what over here
guys
this will be what a ODC over here the
figure is again confusing so this will
be 90 by three six it's a sector with
central angle this into Pi R square
right so Pi into 7 Square over here I
hope it is clear this is the answer to
it now what is the total cost of silver
plating these shaded part A B C D so
shaded part A B C D over here will be
what you have to find the area of this
triangle first shaded Parts area will be
what guys area of triangle a b o
area of triangle a b o you have to find
minus area of this sector uh ocdo or ODC
or whatever it is right and ODC was area
we have already got nine fours are 36
and this will be what 1 by 4 into 22
upon 7 into 7 Square
this will get canceled out over here
and whatever it is you can just simplify
so this is 77 by 2 right 77 by 2 over
here this is the first part of the
question right now we have to find the
area of this region so
minus 77 by 2 is the area of the Shaded
portion right this is the area of the
Shaded portion over here I hope it is
clear now area of this triangle is what
guys this is a right angle triangle and
this is seven so area of this triangle
is half into base into height so half
into base into height I mean these
things are 7 plus 3 is 10 7 plus 3 is
ten so this is ten into ten over here
minus 77 by 2 over here so what is the
answer 100 minus 77
so that will be 23 by 2 over here right
23 by 2 is the answer of the area of
this part and we have to find
cost of silver plating cost of silver
plating rupees 20 per centimeter Square
so the cost will be 23 or 0.2 into 20.
so that will come out to be 46 rupees
right I hope it is clear
not 46 460 rupees I hope the question is
clear to you
huh
yes we'll do that pardeep I hope it is
clear right now what is the length of
Arc CD so length of Arc CD we can
directly see over here length of rcd
will be Theta by 316 to 2 pi r over here
it will be Theta by 360 into 2 pi r
into 2 pi r it's a direct question so
Theta over here is 90 because central
angle is a it's a quadrant over here so
90 by 360 into 2 pi r so 2 into 22 upon
7 into radius over here is 7. so this
will get canceled out over here nine
fours are 36
so this will be 11 centimeter I hope the
question is clear to you
11 centimeter is the answer over here
right so let us move on to the next one
over here guys
okay this is the situation what is the
area of the base of the cylindrical cup
so area of the base of the cylindrical
cup will be what
ah cylindrical cup of diameter this area
of the base of the cylindrical cup it's
it's a direct Circle over here right so
area of the base of the cylindrical cup
will be Pi R square only Pi into R
square is what guys diameter is seven so
radius is seven by two so Pi into seven
by two square so that is 22 upon 7 into
49 by 4 over here so this will get
canceled out
77 by 2 centimeter Square so I hope it
is clear to you
now the next part what is the capacity
of the hemispherical cup so capacity of
the hemispherical Curve will be what
guys its volume over here
so its volume capacity of the
hemispherical cup is 2 by 3 pi r Cube Pi
into R is what over here
diameter is twenty one so R will be 21
upon 2 Q so you can calculate it this
guys this is the capacity of the
hemispherical cube I hope it is clear
now what about the capacity of the
cylindrical cups the direct question
capacity of the cylindrical cup it is
cylinder so Pi R square H it will be so
Pi is 22 upon seven R is 7 by 2 the
whole square and H is what
height is 14. so this is the capacity of
the cylindrical curve what is the curved
surface area of the cylindrical cup
curved surface area of the cylindrical
curve see basically two curved surfaces
are there or not tell me so if if you
talk about curved surface area I would
say you have to take two into two Pi RH
right 2 into 2 pi RH for the cylindrical
cup over here I hope it is still because
it is open from the top and the bottom
we'll do it guys we'll do it just after
this one I hope it is clear to everybody
over here so this was the last question
only right
so just give me some seconds after this
we'll start with the next question over
here right
ah OK after this we will take up the set
three right we'll take up set three
after this one
so just give me some seconds
oh wait one more question is there I did
not see that okay you have got one more
question over here
so refers to any teaching methodology
that makes use of computers and all
these things I hope you understood that
the situation over here now the question
is find the probability that is cool
chosen at random has more than 100
computers so more than 100 computers are
this is the situation for more than 100
computers guys 100 number of schools
they are having more than 100 computers
how many schools are there
1000 Elementary and primary school so
basically the probability will be 80
upon 1000 right more than 100 computers
they are having now find the probability
the school chosen at random has 50 or
fewer computers so 50 or fewer means uh
maximum 50 can be then 50 or fewer So
This Is The Answer over here 250 plus
200 plus 290 so that will be what guys
for the second part it will be over here
uh
740 divided by 1000 over here I hope it
is clear now third second part find the
probability School chosen at random has
no more than 20 no more than 20 means
maximum 20 so this will come in this
situation right so it will be 450 upon
1000 no more than
uh 1000 computers Now find the
probability that school choosing at
random as 10 or less than 10 computers
so 10 or less than 10 means 250 uh
schools over here so the probability is
250 upon 1000 this is the answer to this
question and needless to say I would say
you have you must have written the
formula as well because see that has
come in that sequence to us pradeep I
hope you understand that okay
okay so uh just I'm taking some break of
five six minutes and then I'll be
starting with it okay so give me some
seconds and then we'll be starting with
uh with the next set over here
foreign
Audible and visible to you
yeah yeah five minutes already so let's
let us start with it uh let me see uh
give me some time over here I think
wait give me some seconds over here guys
so this question the r hand of a clock I
think it is there in the set two as well
right this is in the set two as well or
not a set three or or not
uh but I've got set three guys I hope
you understand that that I've got set
three over here and maximum questions
will be same only now in set three as
well they will not be different from Set
uh uh
C so if the natural numbers then which
of the following end with zero so you
have to use the fundamental theorem of
arithmetic the uniqueness part of the
fundamental theorem of arithmetic which
of the following end with zero it's a
very simple thing this is 10 raised to
power n so this will end with 0 right
the uniqueness part of the fundamental
theorem of arithmetic I hope that is
clear and the question which I had
already discussed will skip that part
right so this will end with 0 over here
now what about the next part
so the probability of getting a price
over here so you want a price over here
right
five prices and 20 blanks so that will
be 5 upon 25 over here right so it will
give you one by five the one one by five
is the answer over I hope it is clear
no see that actually it is there on the
slides already now it is fit over there
I hope you understand that it takes some
time otherwise no problem in that
pradeep
so most of the questions will be similar
only you have to find the values of X
Plus y over here so again the same thing
you have to add and subtract right so
over here you have to find the value of
x minus y so what you will do suppose
this is the second equation over here
and this is the first equation over here
so you have to subtract the first
equation from the second equation
subtract the first equation from the
second equation over here so you will
get 3x plus 2y and subtract it you will
get minus 2x minus 3y
and that is equal to 10
so over here you will get x minus y is
equal to 10 so 10 is the answer to this
question I hope it is clear to you let
us take the next one
so questions which are different I'll
take those questions I hope you
understand that okay
so over here a is equal to C is given
right A B is equal to 6 AP is equal to
12.
CP is 4 then you have to find the length
of C D over here
okay a is equal to C is already again
this angle is equal to this angle right
vertically opposite angle so basically
these triangles are similar I can say
that triangle a p a p b is similar to
Triangle a p b is similar to Triangle C
P D over here c p d over here so ratio
of corresponding sides of two similar
triangles are equal so we can say that c
d upon a b a b is six
and that will be equal to ah C P that is
4 divided by A P that is 12 so this will
be what six twos are twelve two twos are
four so c d is equal to 2 is the answer
I hope the question is clear to every
student over here right
I hope you understand that it cannot be
changed immediately like that otherwise
I would have done some of the zeros of
this polynomial you have to find so some
of these zeros is What minus B by so
over here if you take this polynomial
over here
this is 0x guys minus 17 some of these
zeros is equal to minus B by a right now
over here B is nothing but 0 so
therefore some of the zeros is zero
you don't have to actually find the
zeros of this polynomial
so let us move on to the next one
so area of base of a cone is given and
its volume is given area of base of a
cone is given and its volume is given so
area of base of a cone is pi R square
that is 51 and volume is given so volume
of a cone is 1 by 3 Pi R square H this
is equal to 85 over here so from here
can I say that Pi R square H it is equal
to 85 into 2 over here guys
I hope it is clear to you now you have
to find the vertical height so can I
divide this by this guys can I divide
this equation by the sequence Pi R
square H upon Pi R square and that that
is equal to 85 into 2 by 51 so this will
be canceled out so the value of H over
here will be
so this will give you ah the value is
coming out to be
OK this is three I did a slight mistake
this is three over here guys so over
here as well you will get three right
okay so this is three over here so your
answer will be what
five five is the correct answer I hope
the question is clear to you any doubt
in this question
okay I hope it is clear so let us let us
take the next question over here what is
the length of the Arc of a sector of a
circle radius 14 and central angle 90.
so length of the arc you have to find I
think with this question already so
length of the arc is Theta by 360 into
two pi r so Theta by 360 into 2 pi r so
2 into 22 upon 7 radius is 14 over here
so therefore the answer is coming out to
be twenty two just simplify you'll get
the answer
OK it is not visible a bit
so see the questions which you have
already done will skip it the
coordinates of the vertex of this is so
I think this is 3 comma 4 is the answer
so we will skip this one the area of the
rectangle form by this will skip up the
questions which you have already in this
question we did not do in the previous
thing right if you were there in the
class this we did not do it so basically
the r hand of a clock is six centimeter
long
so you have to find the angle sweat byte
between 7 20 to 700 C basically the
angle difference the time difference
between them is what 35 minutes right so
basically our hand cover
the hour hand in 12 hours the r hand
goes 360 right 12 hours the r hand
covers 360 Degrees I hope you understand
that yes or no so it will be what 12
into suppose I change in minute 12 into
60 Minute in these many minutes it
covers 360 degrees or not tell me so in
one minute the angle covered by the r
hand will be what in one minute the
angle covered by the hour hand will be
this
ah it will be this
this is one by two degree right in one
minute the angle covered by the other
hand is one by two degrees so in 35
minutes the angle covered will be 35 by
2 degrees I hope it is clear in 35
minutes it will be 35 but any doubt in
this question
you cannot report it for the I hope you
understand see it's not like that
pradeep I hope you understand I've got
the questions in that sequence now I
cannot
the things has to be embedded on the
slide and something like that I hope you
understand that okay pradeep okay
now the zeros of the polynomial this we
have already done simple question the
questions which we have already done we
will skip those questions right
one zero is reciprocal will we have
already done these things
represent coincident lines we have
already done these things we have
already done some of the roots as four
already done
these already we have done right
now the shadow of a tower the questions
which you have done which will will skip
up right
you see all the equations are same only
this is set three guys this type of
question we also already have done we
have to prove this to be an irrational
number although in the previous set also
it was same but over here values are a
bit different so this you will assume
that this is equal to P by Q where p and
Q are integers and Q is not equal to 0
you don't need to compulsarily assume
them to be Co primes there's no no need
of that in this question so I can write
root 7 to be equal to 6 minus P by Q
over here
so can I say this is 6 Q minus P by Q so
you will write over here see p and Q are
integers so therefore 6 Q minus p is an
integer in the same manner sorry this is
Q over here Q will come in the
denominator guys ok so this is also an
integer over here so the ratio of two
integers with denominator is not equal
to zero is an error is a rational number
so this is a rational number but this is
an irrational number which is a
contradiction and this contradiction
arised due to the wrong Assumption of
taking 6 minus root 7 as an irrational
number hence it is
assuming it to be a rational number
hence it is an irrational number so yeah
you see this is a bit different from the
previous thing
it was not there in the previous set in
the first set it was not there so
therefore I am explaining this one ok
so what you have to do see directly you
know you're not able to understand
anything you just have to change into
sine and cos and simplify you'll get the
answer but I think this is a big thing
so let us start from here
so the let left hand side over you can
change in sign and cos you'll get it you
just have to use identities over here so
10 I can take sine as sine and cos over
here 1 minus sine by cos
plus sine Cube upon sine minus cos sine
Q upon
sine minus cos
this is the thing over here now from
here what will I do you just take the
LCM this will go in the numerator so
what you will get over here guys you
will get cos Cube Theta
divided by cos Theta minus sin Theta
over here and in the denom over here you
have got sine Cube Theta divided by sine
Theta minus cos Theta right sin Theta
minus cos Theta so what I can do over
here
see over here can I take minus 1 is
common in the denominator so what will I
be left with minus cos Cube Theta I can
write it
divided by sin Theta minus cos Theta
plus I can write sine Cube Theta upon
sine Theta minus cos Theta sin Theta
minus cos Theta
so over here you see I can take sin
Theta minus cos Theta in the denominator
so you are left with what sine Cube
Theta minus cos Cube Theta
divided by sine Theta minus cos Theta
right sine Theta minus cos Theta now we
can use a minus B the whole Cube
identity over here A minus B the whole
Cube identity so what it will be guys it
is nothing but a minus B
a minus B
into a square plus b square a square
plus b square
plus a b so it will give you sine Square
Theta into cos Square Theta and in the
denominator you have got sine Theta
minus cos Theta so you have got a
question like this in ncrt guys I hope
you understand that so this will get
canceled out and sine Square theta plus
cos Square Theta is nothing but 1 so you
have got already 1 plus sine Theta cos
Theta this is the solution this is the
proof of it and this is equal to the
right hand side I hope it is clear to
you
I hope this thing is clear right guys
so you see a quad of a circle substance
angle six you find the area of the
corresponding minor segment so it is a
direct question again
it's a direct question area of the
corresponding minor segment you have to
find when the chord is subtending
60 degrees at the center so it is
somewhat like this over here guys so
this is Center and
this is 60 degree over here
and you have to find the area of the
minor segment over here right and
radius is 14 centimeter so area of the
minor segment is what area of the sector
over here sector is Theta by 360 into Pi
R square so 60 by 316 into Pi into Pi
you have to take 3.14 calculation you
have to do guys radius square is 14
Square over here and you see this is an
equilateral triangle wherever central
angle is 60 it will be an equilateral
triangle because you see this angle is
equal to this angle because these two
sides are equal and angles opposite to
equal sides of a triangle are equal so
you can use the angle some property in
this triangle so you will get 2x plus 60
that is equal to 180 degrees so from
here you will get X is equal to 60
degrees x is equal to 60 degrees right
so that therefore it is an equilateral
triangle its area is root three by four
side square root 3 is given to be one
point seven three so one point seven
three by four Side Square is 14 Square
just calculate you will get the answer
centimeter Square
I hope the question is clear to you guys
let's move on to the next one over here
so the questions which we have already
done will skip it these questions they
were already there in set one so let us
skip these questions right
this also we have already done and some
children child must have done it this
also we have done this also we have done
this also we have done this is a bit
different guys so let us do this one
[Music]
32 during the first month receiving the
second one 40 if she continues to save
in this manner in how many months will
she save uh 2000 right so
what is this given guys obviously it's a
question of AP
first month so a over here is 32
36 is the second month so D is what guys
36 minus 32 and that is equal to 4 so D
is 4 over here
if she continues to save in this manner
in how many months will she save so SN
is given to you guys okay
SN is 2000 over here you have to find
the number of terms over here the number
of months over here right
18 question uh what about we are talking
about which question over Sandy 18th
question wait
give me some seconds
where is 18th okay which of the
following some of the roots ah 4 so
option b is the correct answer Sandy I
hope you understand that
okay my son welcome to the session
I hope it is clear
okay fine
so we were doing which question over
here
okay so in how many months will she save
this so SN is given so n by 2 into 2 A
Plus n minus 1 into D so n by 2 into 2 a
that is
n minus 1 and D is over here 4 and that
is equal to 2000 over here so let's
simplify we'll get the answer over here
so we'll get n by 2 into
4 and
plus 60 that is equal to 2000 over here
guys so what we can do over here we can
take
you see we can take 4 as common so four
n by 2 into n plus 15 and that is equal
to 2000 over here guys
so this is two times and this will be
one time over here so 1000 so you can
simplify it and you will get the answer
guys okay
I hope it is clear so you can do it I
hope you can simplify you'll get two
values over here one will be positive
one will be negative will neglect the
negative value because number of uh
months cannot be negative so positive
value can take I hope it is clear you
can solve it right yeah whatever it is
that's what I am saying
so I hope it is clear
okay
so yeah this question uh was there in
the first one and I did not do at that
time you see this one now the proof
based question over I think this one we
are we already did right this one is a
bit uh
so this one through the midpoint I'm of
the side CD of the parallelogram ABCD
the line BM is drawn in the second yes
in so you see this over here it's a
proof based question right so this
situation is somewhat like this or not
if I make the figure according to the
question it is a b
c d over here and it is given that
through a midpoint M of sight CD
midpoint M of side CD you are taking and
basically you are drawing it like this
clear
you are drawing it like this and you are
producing it intersecting
AC in L so AC in L you are intersecting
and a d produced in E I hope it is clear
this is the situation or not now you
have to prove that e l is equal to two
BL the situation clear figure is clear
to you now see the proof of its over
here
what we can do basically
see this is equal to this guys and
obviously vertically opposite angles are
equal this angle is equal to this angle
over here right and also this angle will
be equal to this angle vertically
opposite angles I hope it is clear so
can I not say over here guys uh can I
not say over here that triangle DME you
see triangle DME is congruent
DME is congruent to CMB or not tell me
it is congruent to c m b by SAS
congruency Criterion yes or no they are
congruent by SAS congruency Criterion
so over here if they are congruent can
you not say over here it implies that d
e is equal to BC or not tell me by cpct
if it is visible d e is equal to BC by
cpct so if I take this to be X just
assume that so this is also X over here
clear now opposite sides of a
parallelogram are equal so this is also
X over here just for the time being we
can say that I hope it is clear
now we can use similarity of triangles
right so if you see triangles if I am
saying
a l e can I not say that triangle a l e
is similar to Triangle a l e is similar
to clb or not tell me
c l b by a a similarity correction
because you see this angle is equal to
this angle because opposite sides of a
parallelogram are parallel so they are
alternate interior angles and also
okay a l e and clb and this angle is
already equal to this angle alternate
interior angles so it is correct a l e
and c l b they are similar to each other
right now ratio of corresponding sides
of two similar triangles are equal so
from here what I can say guys can I say
that a e by c b
can I say over here that a e by c b
you see over here a e by c b is equal to
e l by BL or not e l by BL or not tell
me e l by BL
now you see over here a e is what if you
I've just assumed X for that so A E is
nothing but 2X and B C is nothing but X
so can I say it is 2x upon X over here
guys this is 2x upon X and this is
nothing but e l by BL over here e l by
BL so this will get canceled out so from
here you can cross multiply can I say El
is equal to 2 BL guys so e l is equal to
2 BL have we proved it any doubt in this
one I hope it is clear to every student
over here in this session
so let us move on to the next thing over
here right next thing and let's see if
there are some different questions we
have already done this one right in the
previous thing yes we have already done
this one this already we have done this
already we have covered
yup
again this one also we have already got
it means we have already done all the
questions over here so I think how many
students are of set to over here tell me
set 2 over here so if 1 0 of the set 2
we did not discuss right set 1 and set
three we have already done common
questions I did not repeat once again of
the set one because in set one also I
mean obviously many questions are common
okay so set two now we are doing okay so
we will do only non common questions I
hope you understand that common
questions like in which were there in
set one which were there in set three
will not take it over here now I hope
you understand that okay
so ah 1 0 is twice of the other then you
have to find the value of K so you see
over here one zero is twice the other of
a ah the uh one zero is twice the other
it means the zeros are like this or not
I'll find two alpha yes or no one zero
is twice the other so sum of zeros will
be what guys sum of zeros is twelve ah
minus B by a so sum of these zeros is
three k or not tell me so basically
three Alpha 3 Alpha is equal to three k
so you can say Alpha is equal to K or
not tell me
Alpha is coming out to be K or not now
tell me product of zeros will be what
Alpha into two alpha it is equal to C by
a over here so it is two alpha square
that is equal to C by a that is four K
over here this will be 4K now Alpha
Square will be what K Square you see and
that is 4 K over here this will get
canceled or two twos are four so if you
take this up over here so this will give
you K Square
ah minus two k that is equal to 0 so you
can take k s common so K into K minus
two so you have to work according to the
option so K is equal to two is the
answer over here right otherwise K can
be 0 as well K can be zero no problem as
well so this is the answer
any doubt in this question guys
this is set two this is set two you see
it is written already
I can be sure that this is set to only
because set one and set three had
already taken is it clear to everybody
over here or not tell me so let us take
the next one the ratio in which x axis
divides a line segment joining Point C
so any point on the x axis is of what
form guys any point on the x axis is of
the form X comma 0 or not tell me any
point is of this form so you have to
find the ratio so ratio is suppose K is
2 1 so basically it is like this now the
points are
minus 2 comma 3 and 6 comma minus 7
and x axis over here guys
and this point is of the form X comma 0
or not tell me because this is x axis
right this is x axis and just assume
that the ratio is case to one over here
clear or not so we'll use this thing or
not we'll use this thing 0 will be what
guys
m y 2 so it will be minus 7 k
n y one
is it clear
give me some seconds minus 2 comma 3 6
comma minus 7 over here
minus seven so m y 2
so minus 7 K ah
over here okay plus
and Y one I was doing a mistake so this
is 3 over here divided by M plus n
so it will be cross multiplied and it
will be the seven K is equal to 3 so K
is 2 1 will come out to be what 3 is to
7. so 3 is to 7 is the answer I hope the
question is clear to you let's move on
to the next one
okay
ah wait set two questions
I think these questions are different
only in set one and set two ah set one
two and three maybe
because you see this this was case ah
set three
and this is set two over here only these
questions are there up till here I hope
it so any doubt in any of these
questions guys tell me any doubt in
these questions to any student over here
up till here tell me
any doubt in this question to any
student over here guys tell me
so up till here these questions are
there only and
so that's all we needed to discuss over
here and one more thing I see so we are
going to start ntse series as well on
the infinity learn class 9 and 10
YouTube channel see obviously you have
got your examination over today you can
enjoy obviously for the next two to one
or two days I would say please enjoy
that enjoy everything but after that on
Infinity learn class 9 and 10 YouTube
channel we are going to have
ntse Series right wherein we are going
to do the concepts as well as questions
on the basis of ntse and obviously after
that we'll decide on the basis of kvpy
and ioqm and all that as well and with
regards to Jee and need and need angels
are already had explained to you the
batches given by Infinity learned by SRI
chaitanya so those things are obviously
clear and please don't forget to like
share and subscribe uh to our YouTube
channel Infinity learn class 910 in case
of any doubt please post your doubts in
the chat after the class as well you can
post your doubts right it's not just in
the live session after the class as well
suppose you want to it can happen that
you want this you want that so we'll
obviously decide according to our
Arrangement we'll decide that if we can
do but yeah I can say that in the
upcoming future like maybe in the next
one week we are going to start ntse
series on the infinity learn class 9 and
10 YouTube channel so that's all we
needed to do in this class guys bye bye
take care everybody and a very best of
luck for your future endeavors